what comes first the budget or the
script script script dictates the budget
script is your heart and soul the spine
of the whole thing that you're gonna
build off of the foundation of
everything that you're gonna lay on top
of it and if you have money first and
you're writing to the budget of that I
think your creativity is is paramount
and then dealing with in the realities
of you know what's what resources are
available to you right and then you
start talking about money and how you're
gonna fulfill that vision but if the
vision is coming from a monetary I me
personally I I've had more money on some
of my other films didn't mean I did a
better job producing in fact my third
film mother's red dress I had more money
than any of the other ones and it was my
worst job producing why because I
because I thought that by having more
money to pay more money to each position
and person that was working on it I was
just gonna get better talent and
therefore I took my my my better part of
myself out of the equation just that it
was gonna be solved by money and I
learned a very valuable lesson on that
we got the film done and everything was
great and it worked out fine but I I saw
dollars and that I could get this kind
of DP and it didn't translate into
success for the project in fact the
person that I brought on once that DP
left the project for another project in
the middle of shooting yeah I brought in
somebody else that had less equipment
less experience and he did a fantastic
job because his motivation was correct
so so if you if you look at it from this
standpoint if you have money and you're
gonna pay people right I mean we all
want to get paid and we gotta work to
live and all that but but if that is the
focus first then I think that the you're
doing the opposite it's like okay we've
got a marketing campaign we can do no
it's fine to script if it's you know the
the kind of content that we want to sell
as opposed to what come
from within do you think you didn't
screen the people properly because they
were so ready to take the Paycheck that
you didn't see the commitment um I think
it was a combination of that and just
thinking that maybe I had you know was
trying to I think I I took my vigilance
off and and and not qualifying people on
eleven no I had a great time working
with all of those individuals but I
could have avoided a lot of problems had
I had done better vetting of my cast and
my crew that's not to say I regret any
of it because it was a learning
experience and we got a film done and we
did a really good job with it and it
impacted a lot of people but in terms of
my job as a producer I I stepped away
from certain things and just figured
they were gonna take care of themselves
because I had more money that was a
mistake I made
you